I actually was thinking about the very
first time I met you when was it I'm
going to say somewhere around 10 years
ago yeah it was at the sunset Tower
Hotel for the daily the award show oh
yeah and you were winning like the the
basically like goddess in Shell Venus de
Milo Person of the Year yay and I'll
never forget your speech because you
said my mom taught me that there will
always be other fish in the sea and if I
don't act appropriately act humble act
grateful then not only do I not deserve
this but there's no way to carry on yeah
and I was so taken by that oh thank you
no I mean I think that it's really
important
um I'm very grateful for the life that
I've come from and both my parents
worked really hard to give me that
um so I try to be myself and and try to
show so you know people why I deserve to
be there can I add to this please if
that was 10 years ago I'm telling you
she still lives there after five years
of knowing her she's still that person
every day truly like the kindest person
you will meet in fact you two met for
the first time I actually have a
snapshot of the story
so
[Applause]
um so I like the rest of the world fell
in love with
um tan and the Fab Five when queer eye
came out and
all right and
um Eva Chen who I'm friends with head of
Instagram had tan at her office and I
was like this is my chance like I saw on
her stories and like I'm just gonna
FaceTime it was clearly like nine in the
morning and uh like a Saturday yeah and
um we just like hit it off and I was
like will you come to my house right now
yeah and and they came over so that's
right all of America deserved but I just
got that I took it you know what I mean
I ran with it listen go after what you
want and need and look at me now Amanda
said this
I know never never would I have believed
that this is how this was gonna turn out
it's like okay we'll be casual friends
for a little while and then she'll get
overwritten she'll never talk and then
we became best friends yeah and then and
thank God we like working together
because it kind of gone really bad right
yeah you never know you've probably had
friends that like you love and then you
work with them and you're like oh you're
not great I
would you understand that concept
because it's funny most of my
friendships have come from we work
together first and you respect them as
yeah
it really is again it is when you buddy
up because everyone I'm really good
friends with are so close with their
family like we started working together
and then grew a family from that so we
didn't have it's happened to me the
other way where I've what did you do
been friends with someone first then
worked with them and I just
realized yeah it kind of fizzled after
that when I saw them because how did you
how do you how does one skirt out of a
partnership with it it kind of naturally
phase them out yeah it was like it was
naturally like fading anyways probably
for like similar reasons right yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're like with the writings
on the wall let the invisible ink come
apparent
because two hours with somebody and it's
great it's been two weeks with them it's
horrible spend 17 hour days with them
it's rough so you come to her house what
are you talking about with them well it
was it was three of us so it was
actually the Fab three yes it was
Auntie's birthday that day and we were
meant to go out for lunch for his
birthday and I said and look Gigi Hadid
just called and we had only been in
entertainment for three weeks so we
didn't know anyone well Gigi Hadid just
called and she's invited us to her house
I know I'm about to take you out for
your birthday but do you want to go to
Gigi's house and said he was like
now Anthony is one of my best friends
and my neighbor yeah is it amazing to
have these gentlemen in this world and
in this life to help us navigate
to figure out how to live a life America
is so well
that was so nice and you both have
children we do have babies that are like
eight months apart
obsessed
obsessed did becoming a parent like
everything changed for me I didn't know
how to work anymore I didn't know how to
be myself anymore I didn't know how to
be at my other self which I was like are
there two of me one is a work person
one's a yeah just the person at home and
no I think they're the same person but
now my heart is completely focused on
kids and Parenthood so I don't feel like
I can work the same way but I've been on
a track my whole life I don't know how
to get off I don't want to get off but I
need to do things differently because
number one priority is now my kids yeah
what how was it for you guys
uh how is it for you
um I think that it really I mean I was
pregnant during covid which was a
interesting strange was it stressful
because like I just wonder like I was
there was there was two sides to it
right there was like I loved that I was
able to really have my pregnancy be
private and very peaceful and
um obviously I got to stop working a lot
earlier than I would have if covet
hadn't hit
um and but then the other side was like
especially towards the end when like you
get in your head like am I good enough
for this and like you start to like nest
and you're obsessed with like it would
be it would have been nice like get out
of the house and be with friends and be
able to like go to lunch or like just
you know do other things or maybe not
having the we might all die looming and
then yeah that's true also like just
like don't touch anything I was a crazy
pregnant like I would go to the grocery
store and then everything home on the
ground and then from the ground
wipe it down then on the counter yeah
but then I think it really kind of made
me focus on what would help me feel
stable in my work environment
um
with this show consistency yeah like you
and I have this great ability to be
adaptable you're going to this person
place tomorrow you show up on this set
you get to know everyone you understand
how they work how they want to be like
creatively you know how they like this
job to me felt like stability yes
get to go to the same place every day so
the same people there's no like small
talk in the morning like how's your yeah
and it doesn't go away like you know how
many kids they have every day like a new
group of people so this is really this
was my first job working with Gigi after
we had a baby also so it was so humbling
stabilizing and it helped me settle into
oh you can be a really strong parent but
also be a really strong employee who can
have both worlds yeah I didn't want to
give up my career and I didn't want to
give up eloquent he is no he's amazing
he's a thing to pause I I learned so
much about being a parent from G no
really did I not text you a thousand
times saying what would you do in this
situation when I came to your house I
can't get my baby to stop crying like
how do we do this how do I put him down
for a nap and I don't even know what I
remember when I say though you gave you
gave pretty good advice
so I was holding it for eight hours a
day for his naps then Gigi was like okay
I'm gonna give you a tip this is how you
ease out of it she was like put him in
the stroller he can still see you and
walk around your Island in your house
yeah
and then put the island put the stroller
there and just kind of sit next to it
walk away and sit down so you can still
see you and then he'll gradually fall
asleep that advice changed my life thank
you
[Applause]
great advice that is and we're all
trying to figure it out yeah now I've
seen the first two episodes of the show
and I am freaking out first of all this
is one of my favorite shows on
television I love it so much and
second of all
you are so effervescent you are so cute
so goofy sweet she's excitable and it is
so nice to see you come to life because
you are a fully fledged realized person
which is why everyone gets so fascinated
up in your business and how you decide
and I've looked at your journey with
your sister I'm in therapy too I have
been my whole life mental Wellness you
know figuring it all out a boundary I
didn't know what a boundary was either
just just figure that out well you know
what I'd like to pull up a picture of
you
um here is like where you started so
yeah look at that oh I mean can you
stand it and I started at 11 months old
and I do think that by job description
the point of what we do is to not have
boundaries to allow yourself to be an
open vessel
um and so that in itself is very
contradictory to what a boundary is how
are you doing on boundaries I'm good
with boundaries I I think that um once I
worked in in therapy to realize that you
can be assertive and as long as you're
polite that doesn't make you ungrateful
or rude obviously so I think that once
that clicked for me now it seems obvious
but I just started to
um I just started to say what I what I
thought more and as long as I like I
said was polite and
um you know still respectful then you
can say how you feel
[Music]
foreign